your own cup and noodle American ultra
so American ultra stars Jesse Eisenberg
he's dating Kristen Stewart they're both
stoners he works at the little quicky
Mart style store clerk style in then one
day he sees these guys messing with his
cars like hey what are you doing and
armed with a spoon in a cup of noodle he
kills them and you find out this little
stunner yeah he used to be a spy a
badass he's a sleeper agent he's been
targeted for termination by the
government so that's pretty much the
movies these soldiers are coming after
him he doesn't remember who he is when
the situation gets hot he breaks out his
best Jason James Bourne Bond moves and
he starts killing folks really
impressively too and I actually had fun
with this movie first of all Jesse
Eisenberg he is known for playing a
weird twitchy awkward guy this movie it
totally works seeing a weird twitchy
awkward guy play a badass there's like
completely confused he's like I don't
know how I did those moves but I just
killed people it just entertains the
[ __ ] out of me and they did a good job
in this movie even Kristen Stewart was
good in this movie as his girlfriend I'm
gonna say this about Kristen Stewart
right now she has proven that she should
be judged on the merits of the product
that she puts out right now not judged
on the franchise that made her career
that's my way of saying I'm gonna forget
about Twilight I'm gonna move on I like
John Leguizamo in this movie he was a
bit cartoonish ah but I cannot deny I
laughed when he was on screen he just
made me laugh I mean I just had fun with
the characters in this movie this movie
is not supposed to be Macbeth or
anything you're not supposed to look at
the movie like hmm plot holes well the
poem
this is a stoner action comedy about a
stoner who is subconsciously a kick-ass
spy and doesn't even know it in an
action comedy like this you want to
laugh and I laugh you want moments where
someone gets just killed and you're like
is when we had those moments too the
thing that irritated me about American
ultra is that Jesse Eisenberg never
really goes all out in this movie
there's never a moment he's like I
remember everything I remember who I am
and now I'm going to go after them he's
always on the defense he's usually on
the run there's a scene at the end of
course he's like all right I'm gonna go
after them but he's still the little
stoner trying to find his courage I
would have liked to have seen a moment
in the movie where it's like that movie
the long kiss goodnight where he's like
ah I remember everything now they will
get in the sequel maybe we won't maybe
this will have a sequel maybe it won't I
would have liked to have seen here guys
keep it simple because this is a stunner
action comedy it was pretty fun I don't
need to go much deeper than this if you
dig a fun stoner comedy dig some solid
action I think you're gonna have fun
with American ultra to successfully wash
the taste of agent 47 out of my mouth I
had a good time with it in fact I will
say American ultra was a good time no
alcohol or any thrill substances
required
I saw American ultra have you seen it
what did you think about it can you see
how much money this movie's gonna make
this weekend I don't know wise well this
movies Rumble over could go either I
have no idea could make seven bucks this
weekend I don't know whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more